comment fait-on des choix dans la vie
c'est cette question qui m'interpelle en
ce moment alors j'essaye d'y donner des
réponses
la réponse la plus simple à qui me vient
tout de suite c'est la transmission mon
héritage voilà j'ai fait des choix
mes parents sont musiciens je fais de la
musique
super on dit en alsace la pomme ne tombe
jamais loin de l'arbre
bon je suis dans les rails mais ce que
je suis que ça est ce que je suis que
issus de mon héritage est ce que je n'ai
aucun aucun autre moyen de faire des
choix
je réfléchis et je me dis bah si le
plaisir le plaisir guide les choix que
je fais dans la vie mon plaisir mais
c'est pas tous les jours facile le
bonheur n'est pas là au rendez vous tous
les jours mais mais petit à petit je
j'ai avec avec ce guide là le plaisir
quand même j'arrive à construire des
choses bon ok et puis à quelques mois je
vais voir mes parents à nordheim en
alsace il dîne chez des amis leekens des
vieux amis et je les rejoins la fin d'un
repas et la pire qu elle ce je m'assieds
à côté de lui et puis il me prend un
parti en catimini il me dit tu sais on
ai fait des rencontres qu'on fait dans
la vie à 80% et je me dis mais voilà je
ne sais pas pourquoi il me dit c'est à
ce moment là mais je prends ça comme je
le prends j'emmagasine comme quelque
chose de précieux comme un sage qui me
donne une phrase que peut-être fera son
chemin dans mon esprit et ont fait oui
c'est exactement ça c'est exactement ça
je me rends compte là aujourd'hui
que ce sont les rencontres qui m'ont
fait et qui continue à me faire c'est
comme ça alors oui il ya les rencontres
avec mes parents mais bon je n'ai pas
vraiment choisi mais c'est quand même
eux qui m'ont transmis l'amour de la
littérature l'amour de la musique
voilà pourquoi je fais de la musique
mais quand j'étais petite je voulais
faire le choix de faire de la harpe
mon père m'a dit bah non il ya un pied
dans les maisons du fait du piano donc
j'ai pas vraiment pu faire le choix de
mon instrument à la base mais à 18 ans
je suis parti et j'ai décidé de faire du
théâtre
j'avais pas du tout envie qu'on me
regarde je savais pas du tout me tenir
sur sur un plateau gt comme ça j'avais
j'sais pas quoi faire de mes bras et
première rencontre un intervenant
metteur en scène gildas milin qui lui
non plus ne savait pas comment se tenir
sur scène et il a inventé sa propre
méthode en désynchronise en la parole et
le geste est passé quelques quelques
heures avec lui dans ce stage m'a permis
de me dire ok je vais pouvoir inventer
quelque chose qui part de moi pour me
sentir
pour profiter de ce moment là sur scène
devant des gens pour profiter de dire
des mots improvisés ou pas littérature
ou pas mais en tout cas je vais je vais
pouvoir éprouver quelque chose en
partant de moi inventer quelque chose
un chemin et comme a commencé à ce
moment là et puis j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un après un festival littéraire
je faisais un c'était à nevers je
faisais un tandem avec carole martinez
qui est une auteure que j'aime beaucoup
je l'accompagné au piano je chantais
elle disait des textes et l'organisateur
arnaud cathrine qui est aussi écrivain
on
on se rencontre après et on se reconnaît
quelque part on se dit tiens c'est
marrant on a la même manière de
fonctionner on a besoin de vivre tout le
temps des moments intenses et de vivre
vraiment à 100 à l'heure de toujours
dire oui de d'être dans l'organisation à
la fois dans la littérature à la fois
dans le spectacle on a besoin de
beaucoup beaucoup faire tout le temps
rencontrer des gens et on s'arrête
jamais et puis je rentre chez moi puis
là je me mets un disque de barbara et
barbare elle lui dit dans l'îlot mimosas
il ya si peu de temps entre vivre et
mourir qu'il nous faudrait bien pourtant
s'arrêter de courir
donc je me dis ça aussi je le prends
c'est contradictoire avec la rencontre
que je viens de faire mais je le prends
aussi avec moi et puis une autre
rencontre encore la rencontre avec
gwenaëlle aubry
un auteur j'avais rien compris à la
philo quand j'étais au lycée des
pontonniers à strasbourg
et là je vis à besançon c'était il ya
quelques années et je tombe sur ce livre
personne de gwenaëlle aubry je le lis et
je retiens page 81
dans le chapitre i comme illuminé ces
quelques phrases la foule que chacun
clos et recel
l'incapacité à se saisir la foule que
chacun chloé recèlent ces moments où
ravi à soi on a le sentiment de
s'appartenir enfin dans une présence
pleine muette et irréfléchie aux autres
et à l'être à plat je prends ça je le
garde avec moi je vous conseille cette
lecture
voilà ces rencontres là c'est les
miennes c'est ça qui fait ce que je suis
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui fait que je
fais du théâtre que je fais de la
musique que j'avance petit à petit c'est
les rencontres parfois c'est un livre
parfois c'est une personne parfois c'est
tout à coup un vieil ami qui me dit
qu'ils me donnent une phrase et puis
voilà je sais que je suis riche de tout
ça je sais que je vais à cent à l'heure
vient à d'autres personnes encore que je
dois rencontrer bon il ya l'être aimé
mais ça je le garde pour moi
puis à cette personne là je vais bientôt
arriver que je vais rencontrer et il y a
aussi ses textes
ce texte là de gwenaëlle aubry ce texte
là lucas
si tu veux bien d'afficher qui est un
texte de théâtre contemporain de gildas
milin la personne qui ne synchronise qui
dit c'est plus un état d'être c'est pas
quelque chose c'est vraiment un état
d'être plus qu'un état de pensée de deux
de ses regarder je ne sais pas quoi
je ne sais pas pourquoi je me sens site
aussitôt site un site aussi total je ne
sais pas pourquoi je me sens si total
séparer de vous fc us et être eu des
êtres chu sê nique nique nique être
unique et séparé n'est pas moins
merveilleux qu être infinie je vois je
ici je vois ça d'ici ne peut pas ne pas
nous ou ou où je suis vous temps je
sonne je perds perpère jetant je sonne
90 ans personne ne m'entend vous ne
m'entendez pas là où je suis personne ne
m'entend vous ne m'entendez pas on met
en en mai envoie en mai en sage envoie
un message est rien je suis et rien ne
passe ne passent noël elle ne pèse ne
m'appelle pas une république n'arrive
pas je ris venons
je n'arrive pas à dire mon nom
pour finir pour suspendre le temps
petite chanson de barbara
oh
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
on
tu vas partir
oh non tu vas partir
[Musique]
où
ton il
c'est loin pourquoi tu veux savoir
emmène moi dans ton ville
e
[Musique]
emmène moi dans ton il eu loin des rues
main
de la ville
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais dit je t'aime waneux
entre
qu'à moi même
eumeu
je veux partir dans ton île où je sais
que loin des villes
sous des furets assassine tourner des
rondes enfantines sous le ciel et par de
sutter
j'ai vu grandir la misère je n'y peux
rien moi je chante impudique et
impuissante
épargnerait tu les âmes déposerait tu
les armes si je chantais sur ton île
pour toi ça y est loin des vies il
emmène moi
dans ton île loin des rumeurs de la
ville
tu devais creuser ma route et m'écoutent
que mon cou ou de nous notamment dans le
temps merci
[Applaudissements]